[Music]
yeah
[Music]
was it gonna drive you on it yeah it's a
pandemic y'all let's go it's a pandemic
let's go it's a pandemic it's a turkey
it got the itis you know I like this I
send the Colonna to get you it's not a
virus you get that you get that there's
like a coroner but Corona I send the
coroner to get you your boy not finished
finish my man got it down he's not a
clown imma smack you in the mouth if you
come around oh i come around the side of
your cheek hip huh she sucked my dick
now she got [ __ ] let her story that
means my dick was in the booty but oh my
fingers in the coochie uh-huh yeah
Hootie Hootie huh open up your mouth
baby taking the Fed to give in to freak
[ __ ] huh I'm into freaks it I got a
horse pack like the Preakness you can't
see this [ __ ] she blind
10:20 vision your boys on the mission
for the Advil my dicks so heavy it's
like an anvil there's some so my trap
still yeah oh yeah Funk Flex that she
was terrible I just will go that
freestyles call I just woke up
that's the coronavirus freestyle yeah
now I just thought of uh yeah I send the
cornet he gets you it's not a virus on
the way over that's right yeah I like
that like that now that says that's a
solid one as a coronavirus ball right
yeah that one's not actually corny yeah
yeah that one's actually good it's hard
yeah yeah yeah the rest of that though
yes trash yeah WH o is like is like WWE
but for viruses mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
yeah this thing has been wanna make a
gaming team but it's all viruses yeah
all right luminosity bola so I didn't
realize a bola Ebola was like serious
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it was like you got
that and you basically [ __ ] out your
organs you're seriously your organs
melted and you [ __ ] them out until you
died oh and I had a 50% death rate Oh
50% so if you got it yeah in a high ask
ad yeah that's a super high KD yeah
that's a very effective bangin your
whole organ oh man that sounds like a
dream yeah yeah I know that's a crazy
[ __ ] disease that's some [ __ ] what
happens do you just like damn there's
nothing in there yeah I don't know what
if you just got like a little bit of a
bowl oh so you just [ __ ] out one you
look for you do I need notice I mean you
do you [ __ ] out one kidney yeah you
don't need a kidney you it's better to
have two is it yeah it's definitely
better to have two can you have note
what someone what's the thing I'm seeing
spleen yeah yeah you don't need a spleen
yeah you should I your split yeah oh
that's alright that's looking I pooped
out my spleen but it just like takes a
little bit away or something you know
just like it shrinks your left lung just
a little bit it melted a little bit
yeah that sounds horrible oh [ __ ] oh
that sounds awful
running is a lot harder now listen I'm
sorry I'm just thinking here how trash
that freestyle is I feel like I need to
redeem myself
knows what do you mean you want to go in
again yeah could we go in later because
just know as right right man I'm always
down to go in and at any point during
this episode you want to spit some bars
but I just want to pull it back up you
know just cook damn it let's go YouTube
TV two words in this [ __ ] it's the to
add freestyle are we're back in it
alright yeah
yeah yeah let's go let's go yo no I'll
show em how you do it yeah so anyway um
it's just blue ball everybody just never
actually go in yeah yeah you see me I'm
a so much it's up yeah y'all ready some
how you livin huh yeah hey so I'm at the
store yeah and I'm thinking about how um
yeah we know I got some play okay get
him yeah so myself
yeah so the Spanish flu actually had the
exact same death rate as coronavirus
believe it or not so this could be
serious [ __ ] it did it really yeah did
and there was I think there was like 50
million people that died for yeah yeah
yeah 50 million no you know what's scary
is [ __ ] Bill Gates he some years ago
uh they're asking like what his greatest
fear was and he was like my greatest
fear is that there will be a pandemic in
my lifetime and he referenced the
Spanish flu and he's like oh we did the
math if something like that wouldn't
happen now and it would probably hit
about the same number it would kill
about 50 million people as well yeah if
the [ __ ] million people I mean Isis oh
I see like a heavy I see all these
[ __ ] conservatives on Twitter being
like don't you know like [ __ ] it's
just classic media blowing [ __ ] outta
proportion and stuff like that and but
then I watched that [ __ ] episode of
Joe Rogan with this with this you know
is one of the lead researchers in
infectious infectious diseases you know
who's been spend his entire career
researching diseases pandemics how to
stop them he knows everything about
every [ __ ] disease and he's like Joe
was like best case what's the [ __ ]
best case scenario here and he was like
conservatively we estimate with the
numbers that we have from China and
everything conservatively were
estimating 500,000 people died in the
States
I mean like how how could you yeah I
mean you have like I'm not saying panic
but I'm saying just know the [ __ ] and
yeah like really do like stock up on
food if you in case you get it and you
have to quarantine and everything like
you know it's just about like I'm
actually taking this seriously and not
just blowing it off like yeah just get
basic [ __ ] cuz you're not you're not
gonna be like you know yeah you're gonna
feel real bad if you get it or someone
or old that you know gets it and you're
trying to get take care of them or
you're trying to just go to the store to
get Advil and you can't get it yeah you
know whatever just like just grab a
couple basic items it costs you nothing
to be prepared yeah in this situation
yeah that's the thing it's in it yeah
and I just I don't know I just wouldn't
I see all these [ __ ] on my whole
tick-tock feed now is filled with with
people taking cheap flights yeah like
people panicking about coronavirus just
caught that hundred odd flight to bug a
man spring break [ __ ] spring break it's
like I just wouldn't be doing that yeah
yeah I'm crazy man mmhmm yeah yes oh
that's that's why I deleted my [ __ ]
you know tweet making fun of old people
because all the coronavirus memes it's
it's funny now until people start
actually dying yeah I know you're gonna
be like oh yeah yeah that and that mean
wasn't good yeah yeah yeah they're gonna
go back yeah to ten minutes ago on this
episode yeah what works screaming
pandemic over a free YouTube be yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a pandemic you go
and get it that somebody you know they
go and get it
[Music]
it's the pandan that's the new that's
the new ad-lib yeah achoo yeah I'm the
virus baby I don't care about the things
you care about [ __ ] imma air you out
[Music]
[Music]
I'm breathing on you
I'm the colvett bomber the temperature
gonna hit you feeling like you in a
sauna [ __ ] you are gonna yeah this is
my favorite president was Obama there it
is yeah those last four were hot I would
say I won't keep those last four I'm
gonna say those last four we're tight
okay all right yeah anyway I like it um
you like the way I bring that back yeah
hold on wait wait I might have something
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna have some or
run it back yeah I'm gonna have
something yeah they run it back yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go get it go
get it don't sweat it
[Music]
so the hype house dm's me
you